determina las seis razones
trigonométricas para el ángulo
en el siguiente triángulo rectángulo
aquí podemos observar que está el
triángulo
y para ayudarme a recordar las
definiciones de las razones
trigonométricas definiciones hechas por
los matemáticos y que no son muy útiles
para resolver los misterios del mundo
voy a recordar nuestro neumónico que es
sol
y
son tres palabras aunque a veces suena
como si fuera una sola y nos va a servir
para recordar las definiciones de tres
de las seis razones trigonométricas y
vamos a poder obtener las otras tres a
partir de éstas
esta s nos indica que se trata del seno
el pse no va a ser igual a el cateto
opuesto al ángulo de interés entre la
hipotenusa en este caso va a ser el seno
de a así que el seno de a
es igual al cateto opuesto el opuesto
este ángulo va a ser este valor es igual
a escribimos el cateto opuesto opuesto
entre la hipotenusa
y por qué
no sé
aquí tenemos todos los valores el cateto
opuesto que damos que es 12 y la
hipotenusa que es el lado que está
opuesto el ángulo recto es 13 aquí
tenemos 13 y aquí está la primera razón
de las 6 que tenemos que encontrar
ahora pasamos acá la ce nos va a indicar
que es el coseno y es el cateto
adyacente la hipotenusa lo escribimos el
coseno de a del ángulo a es igual al
cateto adyacente adyacente
entre la hipotenusa
y por
usa
ok y esto va a ser igual a el adyacente
al ángulo a es el 5 este lado que mide 5
entre la hipotenusa que ya habíamos
visto que es el valor 13 y aquí está
nuestra segunda razón ahora para nuestra
tercera razón tenemos que esto
t de tangente y lado s opuesto la
adyacente así que la tangente del ángulo
a tangente de a es igual a voy a
abreviar aquí si nos va a tardar mucho
el cateto opuesto entre el cateto
adyacente
tenemos los valores el cateto opuesto el
ángulo a es 12
el cateto o lado adyacente a 5
por lo que ese es el valor de tangente
de a
vamos a realizar las otras tres razones
trigonométricas
que van a ser las recíprocas de cada una
de estas vamos a tener la cosa cante de
a
y aunque comienza con con como de coseno
en realidad es el recíproco del seno así
que va a ser con secante es igual a la
hipotenusa
/
el cateto opuesto así que esto va a ser
igual a 13 entre 12
ahora la siguiente razón es la secante
de a secante de a que es el recíproco
del coseno por lo tanto va a ser
adyacente no no no no no es el recíproco
va a ser entonces hipotenusa hipotenusa
/ adyacente
el valor va a ser 13 en 35 finalmente
tenemos el recíproco del tangente de a
que es la cota en gente con tangente de
a que es igual al cateto adyacente
adyacente entre el cateto opuesto que es
igual en este ejemplo a 5 entre 12 y con
esto ya tenemos las seis razones
trigonométricas que nos pedían en este
problema